seit ein paar tagen ist klar joe biden
wird wohl eher 46 präsident stefan
einigen staaten von amerika beinen
corona bekämpfen das land ein und auch
klimapolitisch einiges anders machen als
sein vorgänger trump student simon green
emotion
unter anderem hatte er angekündigt den
pariser klimaabkommen wieder beitreten
zu wollen
amerika soll mit ihm bis 2050
klimaneutral werden der stromsektor soll
sogar in 15 jahren grünen gemacht werden
außerdem will er rund zwei billionen
dollar in die hand nehmen die
amerikanische wirtschaft
klimafreundlicher zu machen will unter
anderem den grünen infrastruktur und
technologien investieren und eine co2
bepreisung einführen die erwartungen
sind jetzt hoch und die reaktion freudig
und wir fragen uns ist das alles nur
heiße luft
das kann wie so oft nur beantworten
wären die glaskugel schauen kann
eins ist ziemlich sicher globaler
klimaschutz ohne die amerikaner ist wohl
nicht möglich
mit amerika damit zumindest eine chance
warum das so ist hat vor allem drei
gründe
amerika ist immer noch die größte
wirtschaftsmacht der welt der anteil an
der globalen wirtschaftsleistung beträgt
mehr als 20 prozent amerika ist auch
immer noch ein risiko emittent von co2
nach china an zweiter stelle und amerika
hat auch einfach ein enormes politisches
gewicht wenn es um handelsvereinbarungen
und ähnliches geht wenn amerika unter
joe biden das mit dem klimaschutz ganz
nimmt dann ist das eine gute
voraussetzung
zumal sich die amerikaner damit in guter
gesellschaft befinden
damit wäre die sache doch eigentlich
ganz leicht ein amerika das sich dazu
verpflichtet alles zu unternehmen damit
die verbrennung von kohle öl und gas in
30 jahren der vergangenheit angehört so
in etwa sieht es das pariser
klimaabkommen auch vor die erderwärmung
auf 1,5 grad zu begrenzen würde damit
wieder in reichweite rücken das wäre
doch deutlich mehr als heiße luft
das problem ist nur in der vergangenheit
hat das bisher noch nicht so gut
geklappt
ja es hat zwar eine reihe von abkommen
gegeben den letzten 20 jahren angefangen
mit kyoto aber so richtig wirksam waren
sie leider alle nicht auch das paris
abkommen von 215 ist zwar verbindlich
ist zwar verpflichtend für fast alle
staaten der welt aber es funktioniert
eben nicht wenn staaten gegen die
vereinbarung verstoßen heißt
verpflichtung ja sanktionen ein
so gesehen waren die klima abkommen
bislang leider alle wie ein zahnloser
tiger
das ist eigentlich die sag jetzt mal die
epochale herausforderung dieser politik
wir haben es in der
menschheitsgeschichte jedenfalls in den
letzten 200 jahren nie gemacht dass wir
über verträge künstliche knappheiten
erzeugt haben um so ein problem zu lösen
das ist schon das ist eine gewaltige
aufgaben
das große problem in den arabischen
ländern oder auch in der arktis liegen
einfach noch millionen von tonnen öl
unter der erde
auch kohle und gas gibt es im überfluss
auf der welt das würde locker noch für
200 300 jahre reichen um unsere
momentane energieversorgung
sicherzustellen
deswegen ist es einfach viel günstiger
das zu fördern was gerade da ist als
geld in die hand zu nehmen und neuartige
speichertechnologien oder neuartige
fusionsreaktoren zu entwickeln was es
derzeit einfach noch nicht gibt und das
heißt das jetzt genau
naja die weltbevölkerung wächst die
weltwirtschaft auch und damit eben auch
der energiehunger und der co2 ausstoß
auf sicht von klimaökonom einige der
besten davon übrigens aus amerika kann
die lösung also nur wie folgt aussehen
alle staaten oder zumindest alle
größeren staaten dieser welt müssten
sich dazu verpflichten kohle öl und gas
künstlich mit einer co2 abgabe co2
steuer oder ähnlichem
zu verteuern das könnten zb 30 dollar
die tonne sein und genau hier liegt der
knackpunkt denn bisher ist das noch
nicht gelungen auch nicht mit dem
pariser klimaabkommen
ökonomen sprechen dabei vom sogenannten
trittbrettfahrer problem denn selbst
wenn eine zwei oder drei sich darauf
einigen und verständigen kohle teurer zu
machen die anderen aber nicht mitziehen
und machen was sie wollen es dem klima
damit am ende nicht geholfen
wir brauchen preise wir brauchen
transparenz wir brauchen kondition alle
tanzt erst dahin müssen wir kommen ja
green climate fund mit 100 milliarden
ausgestattet der konzern im mittelland
abfließen lassen weil sie gar nicht
darauf ein kann für welche projekte er
bis verwenden hätten man daran co2
das würde man sofort verstehen wo man in
welche bereiche investieren müsste also
das scheint mir ist es ist eine der
aufgaben hört sich unspektakulär an aber
es ist trotzdem spektakulär aber es wäre
zumindest schon mal ein großer schritt
wenn beiden es gelingen würde eine art
klima club klima allianz mit den
europäern und im idealfall auch den
chinesen zu formen co2 in diesem raum
gemeinsam zu verteuern und auch zu
anderen staaten beispielsweise in
südostasien zu sagen hey wenn ihr mit
uns handel treiben wollt dann müsst ihr
das auch einführen
konventionelle pflanzen dass jemand sagt
im multilateralen system ich gebe dir
geld wenn du da für die gegenleistung
bringst ist ein tabu aber ich glaube
dieses tabu muss gebrochen werden weil
wir sonst mit diesen transfers
nirgendwohin kommen wir können nicht
einfach transfers nichts verlieren und
wenn das nicht gelingt natürlich ließe
sich das klima auch auf anderem wege
schützen etwa indem wir so guten ersatz
für kohle öl und gas finden dass wir
diese energieträger gar nicht brauchen
und deswegen auch kein co2 mindestpreis
oder andere verhandlungen brauchen das
kind jetzt alles zugegeben ein bisschen
nach utopie oder nicht ja schon
aber blickt man auf die ankündigung
vieler großer unternehmen ist das
vielleicht gar nicht so sehr zu
filmmusik wie es klingt was machen die
unternehmen natürlich nicht auch selbst
liebe sondern zum einen weil sie wissen
dass ihr geschäftsmodell an einer
endlichen ressourcen und zum anderen
gibt es in kleineren schon heute
erheblichen druck von politischer seite
gibt es schon heute ambitionierte ziele
in amerika zum beispiel auf
bundesstaaten ebene in der eu mit einem
emissionshandel der für die industrie
co2 teuer macht und noch ein zweiter
akteur sitzt in unternehmen im nacken
das kapital und das kommt von
großinvestoren die immer lauter und
schriller und radikaler fordern das
unternehmen gefälligst klimafreundlich
werden und die black box und die
norwegischen staatsfonds dieser welt die
billionen von dollar verwalten
argumentieren dabei vor allem mit dem
risiko dass die raffinerie von heute
morgen nichts mehr wert ist und als
großaktionäre können sie natürlich
erheblichen druck auf die vorstände
ausüben und sogar wenn sie wollen den
unternehmen den geldhahn zudrehen
also können wir mit beiden nun das klima
retten ja und nein ja wenn amerikas
schafft sein politisches gewicht in die
waagschale zu werfen und im idealfall
eine einigung auf einen co2 mindestpreis
gelingt nein wenn die innenpolitischen
widerstände in amerika zu groß werden
und wichtige länder wie china oder
andere große staaten nicht an den
verhandlungstisch zu bekommen sind
aber selbst wenn beiden klimapolitisch
keine bäume ausreißen wird bewegt sich
in der wirtschaft doch eine ganze menge
die nachhaltig diese entwicklung sein
wird das werden die nächsten jahre
zeigen müssen
schwierig wird es allemal
ja das war unser video zum thema
klimaschutz und stroh beiden aber was
glaubt ihr kann beiden wirklich etwas
beim klimaschutz bewegen und das
gespräch mit klimaökonom ottmar
edenhofer findet ihr in voller länge
verlinken